back to the point of you know getting
possibly deep and you know I'm doing
stand up for about two years I think I'm
the fastest comic to ever get a network
special at Showtime so I was like no for
the most part people like oh this guy's
you know two years this is good for him
no man when you do that what happens is
it actually pushes you further away from
them
[Music]
we're live now burning shop what's going
on I'm Sam this is Sean
um we just get right into things but we
uh Sean and I have been huge fans of you
for a long time we're both huge UFC fans
we go to a bunch of those shows been
watching you in front of the kid for a
while uh then the show with Theo Von
yeah that was awesome so we've been fans
forever I think uh we each actually
might have a thick Boy shirt I love it I
love the shirt just the body actually so
I'm a real fan I went all the way Dixon
the heart fellas thinks in the heart I
don't drink otherwise I would have your
your whiskey whiskey but you know you do
lots of stuff uh like I'll I'll kind of
give like what I know about you but
basically you were you're from Colorado
played a little bit uh in the NFL I
don't know if you actually made the cut
entirely but you were like very serious
uh for the Broncos went into the UFC you
did awesome you knocked out some great
guys uh
and then uh you got into Show Business
via podcast so you originally were just
on Joe Rogan a bunch eventually launched
your own thing and now you have fighter
in the kid but you also have like three
or four other podcasts right that I
don't know how how big are they I mean I
know that you get you have uh hundreds
of thousands of subscribers and each
video gets like hundreds of thousands of
views but I actually don't know like how
big the Empire is yeah sure so just
going back to like the football yeah so
I played uh at University of Colorado
for the Buffs who they just got Deion
Sanders so I'm excited about that
um and then I had a a cup of coffee with
the Buffalo Bills and I got there and
they're like we're all set on slow white
guys so that broke my heart and then I
uh and then I uh yeah then from there I
was selling supplements door to door I
like Pursuit of Happiness style and then
I started training in Jiu Jitsu and
boxing and then you know you know I'm
fighting grown men in a steel cage my
underwear and then uh two years after I
started trading I was uh in the UFC I
made it through the ultimate fighter who
has a finalist there with Kimbo Slice
right yeah yeah it was the biggest
season with the shot Evans and Rampage
uh Jackson so yeah then you know shortly
after that you know there's a common
theme in my life it's like I get put in
the deep end man it goes zero to 100 in
every aspect of my life it's just this
common theme throughout my entire career
whether it's comedy football fighting
whatever it is podcasting I get thrown
in the deep and I gotta figure it out so
I was in the UFC and then probably two
years in the UCM 19 I'm ranked top 10 in
the world you know and it was terrifying
um but then slowly after that I um I
moved to LA because I grew up in uh
Venice Beach in the summers at my
uncle's house when I was a young boy my
dad would always bring me out here for
the Summers so I always felt you know a
weird connection to Los Angeles so once
I could make the move I made the move
and then I started a podcast this is
damn near 11 years ago 12 years ago I
started a podcast called The Fighter and
the kid with Brian Cowan
and yeah that thing took off and then
now fast forward to 2023 I own a a
podcast Network so uh thick Boy network
where we have uh you know probably
around seven shows you know so yeah so
between the fire and the kid the shop
show food truck Diaries uh fight
companion uh the golden hour you know
it's uh it's going well it's a lot of
work it's a lot of work yeah your uh
your output's pretty insane and you know
the thing about you you said you got
thrown in the deep end and you're kind
of right like transitioning from
football to UFC was a really short
transition and then you're doing it at
that kind of the high level you're in
the actual UFC it takes most guys like
long long amateur Journey then they go
to a small promotion they go to a bigger
promotion you kind of fast track that
and then in comedy you did the same
thing where you kind of went from I'm a
UFC fighter I'm a comedian so I got a
special on Showtime really fast and I
think there's yeah probably I don't know
I don't know how you think about it now
but like there's good and bad with with
that fast track on one hand you learn
fast on the other hand you kind of get
your ass kicked because you're pushing
the boundary further than maybe you were
ready for or had and you're learning
publicly yeah there you go correct so
it's uh you know in hindsight looking at
it even when I was in the UFC learning
comedy I just I wish I had people around
me that went slow down man now I'm
fighting you don't really have that
option once you're in the UFC
you know it's the big league so you know
they call you with Merkel Crow cop or
Matt mitrione or it's you know Brock
Lesnar you got to take the fight so you
really don't have control there I could
have been smarter about making decisions
when I was young you know and had a lot
of belief in myself and you know
eventually that experience catches up
with you you know I was a lot more
athletic than a lot of those
heavyweights that's why I excelled so
fast but again that's a blessing and a
curse because if you get to a level
where you're fighting these vets with 40
50 fights and they've seen a athletic
dude you know with a good right hand and
you know good wrestling but you know
eventually you know you're this cheat
code and it catches up to you there's
nothing replaces The Experience so
um that was a blasting and a curse a
blessing as far as I was able to
transition get out and build a fan base
and go into something I've always wanted
to do living comedy you know really you
know it's true when I started comedy you
know
um I have some great mentors you know
and Joe Rogan's like a brother and Brian
I have just this plethora of just
amazing Comics that was around and I I
was only you know I'd go to dinner with
them and do all you know the podcasts
with them make them laugh and they all
encouraged me to do stand up which I you
know always wanted to do since I was a
child so
you know everyone told me it's gonna be
10 years before you find your voice I'm
like yeah that one you know I'm never
scared of hard work let's do it so
the issue with that is
you know I get catapulted you know I'm
instead of doing open mics you know when
my first uh things I did was uh you know
Chicago Theater you know um the Vic
Theater which is how did you even start
because it's a big jump from oh this
dude's funny when we hang out cratch
jokes bus ball oh yeah this guy this
guy's good he's a funny guy to you're on
stage and you got to do a set that's
like that's like a it's like a different
thing altogether and you know me and Sam
we try to like um
we try to be uh funny in our little pond
it's like you don't know how to be that
funny to be the funniest business
podcast so we're we're a dwarf among
midgets is what we are yeah it's like
it's like everyone has that funny uncle
at the party you know and if you're you
know if you're your brother's like man I
think you're really funny that there's a
big difference between your family and
friends going oh you're funny man you
should try to stand up and then Burt
Chrysler Joe Rogan Joey Diaz Brian Cowan
Crystal and Theo Von going dude you need
to stand up what did you even do though
to develop that first set are you
reading a book are you uh are you just
going to Joe Rogan's house with a
notepad and being like hey yo how do I
write this [__] oh no it's like sink or
swim soaked you know I had my 10 000
reps on podcasts with comedians keeping
up with them making them laugh being
killed really quick at it and then
really it's almost the perfect situation
in order to get started in stand up
because the final kid got you know so
popular we do live finding the kids but
remember Brian does been in comedy for
30 years so when they we got offered to
do a live fighting the kid I told Brian
I'm like you ever been to a live podcast
they suck it's two guys they're the
worst dude everybody is no man no no
I've been showing business with 30 years
we're gonna do a performance so I go
okay what do you want to do so we came
up with this whole idea to make it a
show and uh Brian at the time knew I
wouldn't do stand-up but he didn't want
to I guess scare me because it is scary
you know just what she's doing friendly
sold out crowds when most people are
doing open minds to 15 other salty
comets you know so for me you know doing
it a sold out crowd Brian go all right
here because Brian was always late to
the podcast you know I'm very
professional I'm I'm not late I'm never
late in whatever 12 years of podcasts
I've never been late it's not what I do
so Brian would be late and he used to
drive me nuts I used to roast him every
time come in late he was like so our
first live show let's keep up with the
theme we're gonna pretend I'm late I'm
not there and you got to start the show
by yourself so you're gonna tell a story
for 10 minutes and I'll come in you get
all upset we do the whole act I'm like
all right cool I'm like I can handle
that so I tell a story just get telling
stories so that carries on for you know
four or five shows and then again we're
at
like for your probably Portland OR
Seattle some sold out theater and uh I'm
backstage before the the crowd I'm
pretty nervous I told Brian I go man I
don't know what store I'm going to tell
and you know Brian was like frantic he
was again he's looking for something he
goes what I don't know what stormy and
tell you what are you talking about
story no you're doing stand-up dumbass I
was like oh and then it just clicked I'm
like oh so storytelling you just told me
that because you don't want to scare me
because crap you're doing stand-up dude
and I was like oh that's what I'm doing
so shortly after that I come to
realization like this is stand up it's
just your way of doing it so then
um we do a live fight in the kid at The
Comedy Store you know the world famous
comedy store which as a kid was like you
know the mecca it's like Madison Square
Garden for basketball so I uh we do
their Comedy Store
goes great and then six weeks or six
days later I'm driving I get a call from
the meds with Comedy Store Emily and she
calls me and she goes hey Brad this is
Emily at the comedy story how you doing
she was a great show the other day I'm
like thank you she goes hey we're seeing
if you'd like to do a set in the belly
room give give you six minutes I go let
me call Brian Cal and see if he's
available she was no dumbass just you
you had a great set the other night like
me you want me to do stand-up and Comedy
Store she goes yeah it's in the small
room in the belly room but if you want
six minutes it's yours so I was like say
less so I did that I mean there was just
you know that was in
2014 2015-ish like early 2015 probably
right around end of 2014 and then just
you know you get that bug and then
it's Off to the Races man you know I
knew it was you know it takes a takes a
lot of work but back to the point of you
know getting possible deep end you know
I'm doing
stand up for about two years I think I'm
the fastest comic to ever get a network
special at showtime and
you know I I just
in in my eyes I thought at the time I'm
proud of that special I challenge any
comment just with that two years two
years to do a network special and have
60 Minutes you know now is it as good as
Bill Burr special no but in my head I
thought
people would see that and go oh my God
for only do it two years look at this
guy see how much better he's gonna get
in four years and five years and ten
years and where's gonna be on 15 years
but a lot of people don't have that
Insight they don't give a [__] about
that yeah they don't see it like that
and you know and again you know this is
a while ago so I was young and I I
always it might be it could be an asset
or it could be a huge gaping hole that I
have but I always see the best in people
in society like I don't pay attention to
hate everything's all good you know I
just I you know I gravitate towards
positivity so I was like no for the most
part people like oh this guy's you know
two years this is good for him no man
when you do that what happens is it
actually pushes you further away from
them I thought it would bring me closer
to being legit and be like my peers no
it pushes you farther away because a lot
of those guys that I mentioned earlier
on and even outside of those guys a lot
of famous comedians it took them 15 20
years ago Network special so there's a
lot of
it's not even jealousy it's just like
you know it just rubs people the wrong
way and I didn't see that coming I gotta
be honest and I don't think really
anybody did you know but it is what it
is you know you do that and you move on
and you just keep grinding and you go to
the next one the next one so
um yeah it's been interesting man it's
been really interesting I learned on the
Fly I also learned the hardest way
that's the only way I make changes I
learned the hard way so
um I wouldn't change anything you know
things are pretty good are you the the
CEO of the network now I mean so you're
having to be the talent and you're
running the business yeah heavy lies the
crown man so I grew up in a
business-minded family my dad's
entrepreneur
um you know she's always been
business-minded I have a a double major
from University Colorado and sociology
and business so I was gravitated towards
business
and you know I worked for showtime for
six years I built the entire you know
podcast branch which is crushing it now
and shout out to Brian Daly and you know
at the end of six years so this is
December last year 2022 six months prior
they offered me another six year
contract and I I'm just looking around
and Showtime was great to me you know I
was getting a salary and you know
they're reaping the benefits it was good
for both sides I thought man I I feel
like I could do this on my own you know
I am an entrepreneur I feel like I could
I see what they built and you know and
I've helped them out a lot they've
helped me out a lot I feel like I can
invest in myself and do this on my own
so I turned down the contract I was like
I'm gonna do it on my own start think
boy Studios and I owned all the IPS to
all the shows that I started with them
so I brought that over and it's you know
in hindsight I didn't there's Eli I
don't really know who to talk to nobody
in my Lane kind of has done this where
you leave a major Network in podcasting
and bring it over on your own
and it's a different animal when you're
not only in your talent but you're also
running because you're very busy raise
money for that or did you just self-fund
it what'd you do yeah I still funded it
from all the other shows and stand up I
just put all my money into that and then
whenever I start a new thing I'm like
you know people are like oh congrats and
I'm like ah ask me in a year like we'll
find out what's gonna be fun to find out
like this is either a bad idea it's an
all right idea or it's an amazing idea
we'll find out because you know I go
into things relatively blind like I
don't do a ton of research before I go
into things but I you know I Got
Confidence I'll figure things out
eventually but the reality is that some
some ideas are better than others so a
year in now
owning your own podcast network is this
a bad idea good okay good idea or is it
an amazing is it an amazing business I
think it's still too early to tell oh
medium where you're in
financially am I making more money yes
but you know that can't just be the the
main focus you know because my life's
more complicated you know my life's more
complicated I have less free time so
what's that worth you know so there's
like these pros and cons I didn't think
about because at Showtime I was the
talent I would create shows they would
make it happen you know and they would
have the employees and the creative team
and the producers and the editors and I
was I would come up with ideas they
would execute it I would sit down knock
it out great get paid for that and move
on and just not worry about to you know
the next day or the next week now it's a
little different now you know
um
I would say one of my biggest kind of
um faults is
not like I'm a control freak so I need
help and and I'm getting there and I
just you know you want somebody to care
as much about your business as you do
it's impossible to find and you know
with Showtime
there's CBS so they're doing all the
right stuff as far as hiring and you
know and bringing the right people and I
didn't take that in consideration like
hiring you know heart is not find good
employees and people that actually care
and can get the job done they mold with
the team and gel with the team so it's
just those kind of Dynamics not even
think about and also when you're at
Showtime you know for six years and we
started with zero subscribers and then
six years later at like 600 000 you know
well known in the space we're up for
awards you're starting from dead zero
again so that's six years that you built
for them that doesn't come with you I
don't own that Showtime page that's
there so you just start from zero again
I think we're like 160 170 000 now a
year in which isn't bad but it's you
know it takes time to keep chipping away
chipping away so what about uh listener
like Sean and I the metrics that we know
is downloads which is when we describe
downloads as like Spotify YouTube and
also I iTunes and all that [__] what do
you what's the size of your biggest show
I think is fire in the kid what what
size are you guys at now for that we do
we look at it per episode because
otherwise you can get a lot of downloads
if you just pump out more and more
episodes like per episode is the real
real deal for I think for for these
shows well see so exciting the kid and
the golden hour which is formerly known
as king of the Sting with Theo Von so
finally kill the king of Sting even
though they're on the thick boy
networked those haven't changed just
under my banner but those have those
weren't part of showtime at all Showtime
was uh below the belt which is now the
shop show food truck Diaries
um and some other shows and then I
wasn't doing fight campaign with them
that's all new so you know I would say
they probably cut my audience in half
you know probably in half but and what
what's the fighter and the kid at
five's a kid I mean now now we're going
down uh you know you're going down a a
different road because there's factors
there that have
you know cause that show like you know
you want to do it for 12 years it's like
this you know it's like this so you know
we've been as high as 600 000 episodes
as low as a hundred thousand episodes so
that that and it's you know there's been
some outlying factors you know that that
cause those issues so
each and that with the changing of King
of The Sting with Theo leaving you're
talking about a whole new show so you
start from basically from scratch again
to start with Chris Delia and Eric
Griffin it's completely different show
the Dynamics completely different so
you're re-inducing that show to kind of
although there was an audience there I
think we're at 500 000 subscribers those
500 000 subscribers were there for
theobada Brenda job so when you go all
right well here's Brandon and crystally
and Eric some people will know we'd like
to dial it with Theo and Brendan so
that's fairly new you know that's about
six months old so you know that one's
probably around 150 200 000 just on
YouTube but um I think a lot of people
in podcasting because it's the thing in
2023 is they look at YouTube YouTube
YouTube YouTube
adios King molt for the most part people
listen to podcasts on their way to work
or when they're at the office they'll be
sitting down watching a podcast for two
hours or three hours however long your
podcast is the audio is K so my main
metric that I focus on is always audio
now if audio starts to go down we got
problems yeah we're at like when we
we'll have guests on every once in a
while and they'll be like are you guys
big and they'll just look at the YouTube
and like our YouTube only gets like
thirty thousand twenty thousand all the
way up to 200 000 per episode but then
our audio it's like consistently 100 200
000 ish or something like that like
consistently every single time correct
and that and that's crushing it and I'm
like no it's pretty big it's just like
you can't see those numbers but our our
audio I mean it's like that's like as
true to subscription as you can get
because it's just consistently a big
thing yeah adios came with this new
generation of podcasters coming in you
know you see the Logan Paul's or the
Andrew Schultz of the world and you know
Rogan was massive on YouTube but it's
again and I don't know what Logan Paul's
numbers are as far as audio Logan Paul's
a buddy I guess I could find out but
because he's a YouTuber just his numbers
are massive on YouTube I'd be curious to
see what his audio is like because again
audio is Canyon podcasting so I never
focus on YouTube too much now if there's
a decline you're like all right we gotta
figure this out and we'll work to it but
it's my audio solid I don't you know I'm
not there's no red flags what's your
ambition level in terms of this business
like are you are you are you thinking
like I think we can get to 10 million in
revenue or is it like I want to exit for
100 million I think we can get the 50
million in Revenue where do you where is
like your
not quite North Star but like your two
three five year goal yeah that's a
that's a great question
um Rob Dyrdek's a good buddy and she's
such I don't know yeah Rob Derek would
be great for you guys we've had we've
had him on and he killed it we we were I
I think we were a little bit early in
his like public business Persona and we
had him and he blew us away he was
amazing yeah I've known Rob for years so
I've always knew he was just like Savant
when it comes to business he makes so
many great decisions and he came into
the thick boy studios here in Calabasas
and
I was probably I don't know she's two or
three months into it you know so you're
still trying to figure it out and he's
looking around and he's like man this is
cool and he's asking all these questions
they kept going you know what's your
goal what's your goal watch your goal
and finally I think he was even out
there I'm like Dia chilled dude I was
like um let me get to cruising altitude
and get to Wi-Fi before I start figuring
out goals like this thing's just taken
off once I get to cruising altitude I'll
let you know the goal so we're kind of
getting to cruising altitude I I you
know I don't know what the goal is I
think once I get to
the network where I think it could be at
that I would start looking at other
options but the other thing I would say
too when as far as business whether it's
whiskey and merge whatever it is even
stand up podcasting I've never done
anything for money ever I do it because
I love to do it and it's fun for me and
it's what I want to do and if it makes
money fantastic man that's great but if
it does it all good it's something I
want to do so hopefully this thing goes
great and makes a ton of money and I can
retire when I say retire do less shows
but with just more money in the bank but
um I love doing it that's why I started
it so so hopefully you know when we do
this show in you know three years or
five years I'm talking to you guys and
we're celebrating some big moment but I
couldn't tell you what that looks like
and that might be a problem I mean you
guys are the business guys is that a
problem that I don't have some sort of
end goal here even though so I don't
think you got to have an uh and like
what people want like a five year plan
and you kind of taught this at a young
age like you're 18 years old what you
going to major in not as hot dude I
don't know I don't know [__] about [__]
yet
um yeah so people are often pushing for
that it's great when you have it so I
always say that if you know the
direction you want to go you know the
outcome it's great when you have it but
the reality is most people don't have it
right off the Jump and that's totally
normal you just got to get in motion get
momentum because as you start going
you'll start navigating you'll get a
better vantage point it's like you start
climbing the mountain you're higher up
you could see more and that'll give you
a little more but I do what I do think
helps is a vision for your life so a
vision for like which what kind of what
do you want to do with your life your
talents or like so for example I might
not know I'm trying to hit this Revenue
Target I'm trying to sell in X years or
whatever but I do usually know man it'd
be [__] awesome if dude what if my
job was I literally get to sit down with
my friend Sam and we just shoot the [__]
about business and what if there were
millions of people listening to that
wouldn't that be cool yeah all right
that's literally when I started this
podcast it was I was walking around with
a friend we had just signed the
paperwork to sell my my first company
and he was like what do you want to do
next and in Silicon Valley where I live
there's only one answer I'm gonna start
another company it's gonna be bigger and
badder than the one before that there's
only one socially acceptable answer in
Silicon Valley it's like in Hollywood if
you're not trying to make it what are
you doing here and so but I gave him the
honest answer I go you know what I think
what Tim Ferriss does is awesome it
seems like that dude gets to wake up
just be curious about [__] run
experiments learn about things and then
he just takes the coolest stuff he
learns he just gets to talk about it and
a million people have him in in their
ears and he gets to influence a million
smart people by sharing little nuggets I
go that would be awesome I want to be in
a million people's ear balls and that's
just what I kept saying I want to be in
a million people's ear balls he was like
dude I never even heard that word but
like he goes That's a like that's like a
vision for like what would be an awesome
life so I I think that sometimes you
don't have to have the number but it is
cool to have a man that'd be awesome if
my life was X or if I was able to do
that do X I remember uh I remember
talking to you guys know Justin Khan
Justin so Sean actually sold his company
to Twitch Justin Khan's one of the guys
who started twitch you know they sold it
for a billion dollars I I was talking to
him backstage one time like two years or
three years after the sale
we're at uh an event I was hosting and
he was like I was like what are you
gonna do next Justin and he goes
10 billion I want to go after 10 billion
and uh it didn't work it didn't work out
for him by the way it didn't work out
and like he I remember I read like this
blog post where he was like I was
motivated to like out and do what I did
before partially out of like it was like
it was like rage like out of Rage out of
like a chip on my shoulder which is
actually I think great fuel but like I
was in it for the wrong motivations and
it didn't work out but yeah something
Sean has said that I said it differently
but he said it better which was uh abz
which is like I I like to do this all
the time I'm like all right step one is
a step two is B I don't need to worry
about anything else in between that but
step Z is like one day maybe maybe one
day this becomes a billion dollar
company but let's just focus on getting
to a million in revenue or let's just
focus on like paying the rent and then
after that maybe we could hire a handful
of people and then I'll figure out the
rest but maybe one day it could become
this and that's like a fun way to like
that's like a fun North Star to like
help some decision making it's also very
motivational you're like I'm doing this
for for this reason yeah
it's also less pressure where you know I
and you know I think happened that
entrepreneur spirit that I was born with
from my dad you guys it seems like you
guys have the same thing too you have to
be the success you breached uh you know
I never stop and smell the roses ever
it's always what's next what are we
gonna do next and What Makes Us
successful and this next thing the next
thing and in my sports career and even
in comedy I've never just stopped and
you know smelled the roses I'm
constantly constantly pushing constantly
pushing you know I don't know if that
leads to happier life you know I think
sometimes you need a check and go if
you're doing it's all good man if
nothing changes your life's pretty
freaking great man if you just stay here
it's all good but I I wish I was more
like that you know I
I don't know what else I could get that
would make me happy I guess if uh you
know if I'd have to fly commercial my
life would change that'd be great you
know but outside that like things are
going to apply private you mean yeah
yeah if I didn't have to fly commercial
I hate flying but well yeah hey I I see
you got the nice 911s you got the cool
Ferraris I mean you got the toys yeah a
nice next step yeah if you had told 10
year old Brendan you know some of the
stuff you'd be doing some of the stuff
you'd have he'd be like holy man this is
insane dude good for you you made it but
I don't feel like we always talk about
on the Pod we say a lot of people ask
like what advice would you give your 21
year old self or your your 15 year old
self and we asked the opposite questions
like what would our 15 year old self say
to us now if it could look at our life
now be like dude you're unhappy look at
your [__] man like are you joking you
got to barely heard you get to do this
every day like you better be smiling bro
like that's what that's what my teenage
self would be telling me right now uh
and that's almost a good reminder it's
like like I always say dogs and kids got
it figured out and and uh I want to be
more like I want to learn more and be
more like my dog and my kids because oh
dude all day is play everything is good
they're happy they're grateful like we
get we get things screwed up when we get
older and do you guys have kids I got
two little ones yeah I have a seven and
three year old and I don't think I've
ever been this happy in my life as my
two boys were yesterday I bought them
two but I brought three lizards I was
like man if I could just that level of
Happiness one more time bearded listener
one time my life is complete yeah can
you give you a different perspective on
things man you know I might be stressed
out about work so I might come home and
that stuff goes out the window you know
there's nothing better than being a dad
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobbled
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better uh Tony
Robbins if you ever I don't know if
you've ever been to one of his events or
or looked into no pissed off like most
people think oh Tony Robbins I I don't
need motivation or that's like a cult
thing or whatever I've been to a bunch
of them and I found it really really
useful it's a good I don't know I'm not
very religious so it's a good operating
Philosophy for life but one of the
things he says is he's like
you got on one hand the the the sort of
the the science of success and that's I
think what you've kind of done done well
which is whether I'm going into football
or fighting or comedy or podcasting or
now the business side
there's the the science of success is
basically like there's an approach to
set you know figuring out a Target
working hard every day making progress
like taking it seriously all that stuff
and then there's the art of fulfillment
and they're unrelated and if you want to
have like the full the complete life you
got to figure out oh just like I learned
the skills of how to be successful I got
to learn the skills of how to be
fulfilled and the magic happens when you
sort of integrate the two can you both
like create new projects and try to be
successful while being fulfilled because
what most people do is they go for that
success thing mostly from a point of
view of like um
you know try to prove themselves or it's
like a some some insecurity a lot of
times that will drive it
no I love that yeah I think uh yeah for
me I do a pretty good job of trying to
stop and smell the roses a little bit so
I'm doing a better job my kids helped me
get there and then I think a lot of
mistakes that people make whether it's
business entertainment you know stand up
comedians is especially with social
media now that's why I'm not a big
social media guy is you can always
compare yourself to somebody doing
better so for your friend that made a
billion next thing was 10 billion
because he saw a guy make 10 billion so
if you're constantly chasing that
compare yourself to others that's where
the happiness never comes so I try not
to compare myself to the others
especially me because my Journey's so
different than those guys that I look up
to so you know my Journeys can be
different man whatever that looks like
and I just have to accept that which I
try to do Sean and I
yeah I was I was reading some of the
yesterday that reminded me of you and
which was uh I was reading a blog post
Sam put out this great tweet asking for
what's the best blog post you ever read
and one of them was this thing called
the the uh the was it the physics of
passion he basically goes uh there's
this thing called the Kool-Aid point so
he draws this graph he's like as you as
you do [__] and people start to like
your work or admire you or love you or
become a fan of you you'll it kind of
grows steady steady steady and then
there's this point uh he calls this the
Kool-Aid point where it kind of takes
off it goes then you're gonna have two
groups of people you're gonna have a
bunch of people that love you and a few
people that hate you and he goes what
happens is here's how you'll know you're
there people accuse your fans of just
drinking the Kool-Aid they love
everything you do beside unseen and
they're Kool-Aid drinkers that's how you
know if you have people that can be
described as that you've hit the
Kool-Aid Point yeah I love that on the
other side you're going to have people
who want to tear you down are the haters
you know quote unquote and uh and and
you know at first they're they're always
a small group but they're kind of loud
and some people even support them and be
like oh you're you're speaking truth to
power you're you're calling it like it
is you're kind of exposing this person
or this this brand or whatever it is
yeah and you got both and so I was
reading that and I knew we had this pod
today and I was like oh dude he's he's
live he's lived that point because yeah
so you know you have for people who
don't know
you got a big fan base you got a big
anti-fan base and uh the anti-fan-based
I think it's on on Reddit I go to this
subreddit a bunch but I'm not like like
it's weird I like you but I also find it
funny like they're so clever these
people are not so funny but they're also
funny in the same way like it's kind of
this this double thing I'm curious like
for you obviously that's like you know
it's probably funny for me because I'm
outside of it I'm not the person that's
the butt of the joke in some of these
cases but
you know me and Sam got maybe 1 100th of
the like kind of the the passion and
hate that you that you have because
you've been doing this a long time
you've you've made it pretty big
but when I read our YouTube comments and
I see something like that it stings in
the moment but also there's a lot of
times where I'm like they're not wrong
like
you know uh there is there is some truth
where they're they're being a dick about
it but there's some truth to where what
they're saying I I could see that I'm
curious for you when you when you hear
about the the sort of the stuff on the
subreddit or you check it out or
whatever
do you have any moments where you're
like all right they're kind of being
mean about it or they're being a dick
about it but there's some truth to what
they're saying
I mean yeah I'm sure you know I don't in
all honesty I I don't pay attention to
it I think you it's a it's a bad thing
whether you pay attention to the
negativity or the positivity yeah I
think you just gotta keep doing your
thing you know my heroes growing up
didn't live this world you know so it
can't be healthy I think we'll find over
years how it affects the brain how it
affects creatives and businessmen with
who do pay attention to that stuff and
read the comments and stuff like that so
I don't want to be that sample size I'm
not going to be trying to get that
digital CTE
comments every day yeah I already have
enough CT man I'm about to ride my
Porsche off the PCH but um I think with
the Reddit group yeah it's interesting
because
you know the watch everything you do and
there's there's some things that I'm on
board with and then the only there's a
small select group on there who are just
evil so there's difference between hate
which I get I give you a lot to hate on
I do a lot of content I make a lot of
jokes I send a lot of people I get that
you don't get to a certain level without
giving you a lot of haters you just
don't if you look at Logan Paul Drake
Lebron James name some the massive
celebrities that we have in this world
there and you go online you read their
comments or My Buddy Joe Rogan nobody no
I don't know anybody gets more hate than
that guy he gets more love you know I'm
in the business of likability so if you
watch my podcast you buy a ticket to my
stand up you buy the merch you buy the
whiskey you're a fan I make a living off
like ability so I just don't I don't
give the hate energy as far as the
Reddit goes I get it and some of them
are really funny and I appreciate those
guys whether it's good or bad towards me
it gets a little dicey when they they
want to I just I don't understand when
they cry when they cross the line when
it gets into my personal life right it's
like I'm not Tom Cruise dude why the
[__] you give us who cares about that
stuff you know and thank God my wife
she's been with me since I was in the
UFC so when you're fighting UFC you get
a lot of love you get a lot of hint
there's no in between if you're doing it
right so she's conditioned to that she
doesn't pay attention to it she doesn't
care you know at this point so thank God
for that but the only time I don't like
is when they make it super personal it's
about the kids it's about you know
certain things but you know nobody's
harder uh on on on me than myself you
know there's nothing they can say that I
don't tell myself usually on a daily
basis and trust me it's way worse
whatever they're putting out so although
I you know I get it I appreciate it and
you know I just don't give it energy I
think one of the things that I
have going for me is you know I post and
ghosts I don't pay attention to that
stuff but then I'm also you know I'm on
the road whatever it is 30 weekends a
year I you know if I I get done this
interview I go get coffee I can't go
down the street without so many 10. hey
Brandon love you man so that's real
that's what I care about social media
it's a factor for sure but it's not the
end-all be-all I think when people
realize that that one in if you're
walking down the street one to ten
people on social media especially on
Twitter that you can't give yourself
value your self-worth of what social
media is you're going to live a much
happier life so that Reddit group
they're gonna do their thing you know
and that comes with their territory and
I was built for that's why God give me
big shoulders but
um you know they're gonna click that
they're gonna love that one
yeah I think I was built for it and then
also you look you know if you look at me
I know you know I probably look like the
guy that bored you in high school they
needle to use some of that you know like
oh Brendan's a bully or whatever and I
know I look like the guy but if they
actually knew me know these people know
me they've never met me you know they're
not buying tickets to the show so I
don't give it energy because if I did I
wouldn't have a business I wouldn't have
this house that I'm talking to you guys
in right now so
um you know I think it it get the lines
get blurred where it's like oh he's a
big strong guy he's fighting here see he
can handle this we there's no limits
everything's on off limits he there's
nothing off limits we can go as hard as
we want him it's like it actually hurts
my feelings man it's actually not cool
you know but I joked I'm all for I'm all
four man I'm professional comic we roast
each other we do our thing so if it's
funny it's witty fire away but when you
start going towards the once once you
start going towards the personal side
well then you've crossed the boundary
you know and now also if you want to
have this conversation in person you
want to offend me we can do that I can
do that we can see how it goes for you
that's never happened as long as long as
I've been in entertainment I've never
run into anybody that said something to
my face so I just I get what they're
doing if it's funny it's witty and
they're gonna do their thing I actually
appreciate it but when you cross the
boundary and you did you disrespect me a
different way
you know that that's where I have an
issue with it what is the issue with it
means it hurts my feelings I'm not gonna
do nothing dude I'm not gonna beat I'm
not the bully you expect me to be and
then also I think that that subreddit
has crossed the point not all of them
some are actually just funny and they're
fans and they just show it in a
different way and I understand that at
my age but you know a lot of them have
crossed that boundary where you know
they hide behind this gboard and they
want to do evil things which I just I
don't understand that's to me it's like
and for why for what because I do stand
up you don't have to buy a ticket
because I do free podcasts that triggers
you right we don't have to watch you
know so I just I'm just cut from a
Different Cloth I'm just a positive
person now there's some podcasters that
will lean into it and if there's beef
between Comics the lean into that and
they like that that controversy and that
drama all the time like it's real
housewives of LA and I would probably be
much more famous than much more further
along my career if I entertained that I
just can't do it sometimes I think man I
should try that it's just not what I do
I don't like being negative I'm a
positive person I enjoy helping people
out so you know it's just heavy lies to
Crown with that stuff man you were you
were saying how when you moved there's a
lot of rent I apologize no it's good
they're a whole you know someone's got a
clip that some hater will clip that
hopefully but somehow hopefully that
hate pushes us forward somehow but you
were talking about moving to LA and how
that was like a big change you basically
like Sean and I both lived in San
Francisco when we started internet
companies and like having a crew we were
in each other's crew we had a handful of
others where you like succeed together
that's like the greatest thing ever
because like it's it's hey it's fun and
B is actually useful like you piggyback
off each other and you and you motivate
one another and you actually like you
invest in each other whatever it's like
practical
you're in this cool world it's like you
Bobby Lee Theo Von crystalia Andrew
Santino uh Andrew Schultz is a little
bit outside of that but somewhat inside
of that Joe Rogan yeah you got this like
crew and like it doesn't like 10 years
ago you know there was Rogan but there
weren't really like a lot of like comedy
YouTube channels like or podcasts but
right now like if I go on my YouTube app
like it's basically like a Theo Bond or
Brennan job clip like constantly or like
the clip of Bobby Lee tell the story
about uh uh that's gonna be the most
viral clip in uh comedy podcast history
that was hilarious yeah it's so funny
where he talks about getting molested by
a Down Syndrome guy it's one of the
funniest I mean and so like I can't go
on without seeing like a funniest bits
from whatever like and it's like someone
in your crew what's that like behind the
scenes like are you guys uh is this like
a um like Sean and I sometimes when we
want to get like popular on X Y and Z
we're like hey can you like this can you
share this or hey do you want my thing
you come like it's like it's it's
somewhat organized somewhat or just
sharing like we're just sharing being
like yo I'm doing this and it's working
like uh yes you know um what's that like
you know what you have like a group text
when you're like hey Theo like uh I
found that like this type of like
because you guys and then by the way I
don't know if we told you this if you go
and look at when we first started MFM my
first million we just bought the same
[__] red sofa lounge chairs that you
had because I love it because I would
see those on the I would see those in
the thumbnail and I'm like yeah all that
red like you make it makes you want to
click it and I noticed that you and Theo
particularly you I bet you probably
started it you have these like pretty
eye-catching Studios they're not like
particularly fancy but they're just like
they're just like an eye-catching and
you're changing them constantly and I've
noticed Theo's does the same thing he's
constantly changing the set same with
Andrew Schultz are you guys like sharing
all these tactics like uh when we're
doing this it's working or like here's
how much we're paying for it blank or
like you guys let's pump each other
around this thing yeah you know so going
back to kind of the the whole like kind
of it was almost like a team you know
and I you know the team captain all this
starts from Joe Rogan so before I hit
the comment but he doesn't give a [__]
about any of that does he he just does
whatever the [__] he wants in it
sometimes it works he does whatever he
wants and he's the leader of the pack
but he's also the reason why we Embrace
each other and you know five six years
ago seven years ago at the comedy store
is the comedy wrap pack and we were the
we were the Rat Pack and we were the
guys and every show sold out our names
on the Marquee and Rogan there was a
there was kind of uh you know their
structure like we don't tear each other
down we support each other
um and I heard Isaiah Thomas say this
when he went on uh my uh boys podcast uh
all the smoke with Matt Barnes
um and uh Isaiah Thomas said this and it
really resonated with me he was on there
he's talking about Michael Jordan and he
goes
and clearly I'm not a black man I don't
know if you guys know this or not but
I'm not black but it's actually not that
clear by the way you could be you could
who knows what I am dude if you told me
you had a little in you it wouldn't be
surprising yeah
earlier when you said uh Denver or
Buffalo Bills didn't want slow white
guys I was like yeah so you're in yeah
so you made the team right yeah right
now tell me you're not Aaron Hernandez
no but um
so uh where was I oh so we're this
coming Rat Pack no no you're saying
Isaiah Thomas said something yeah Isaiah
Thomas yeah so Isaiah Thomas said this
and I saw a clip that Matt Barnes post
and I love those guys I started with
them at showtime and they're crushing it
but Isaiah Thomas they brought up
Michael Jordan and Isaiah Thomas has
issues with Michael Jordan and uh Matt
Barnesville we'd love to have them on
and uh Isaiah's like it's a tough one he
does do interviews then Isaiah said as
an alumni from the NBA as as alumni and
you guys are alumni we're this tight
fraternity and not only are a tight
fraternity that we've reached certain
levels of the MBA in this you know in
this Lane that we're in but we're also
black men and it is our duty to support
each other it is our duty to come on the
shows and make sure you guys get views
make sure people get your name out there
that that is something that has it's our
responsibility being in this small group
in this small club and back probably
seven years ago you know Rogan it was
the same thing it is your [__] it is
your duty to come on other shows to
broaden the audience to bring everybody
into these great talents you know
whether it's you know back in the day
find the kid outside Joe Rogan fine kid
was the wanting pad if he goes through
it you look at Tim dill and Andrew
Schultz centino Theo Von Crystal it you
look at all the people that came on
there and just exploded now is it
because it the final kid audience maybe
helped a little it's because those guys
are so goddamn talented and once people
saw who they were they out succeeded
finding the kid they've gone on they've
blown the roof off things now but if you
look back on finding the kid and I take
so much pride and joy in that where we
have these guys on before they are
massive and as Isaiah Thomas says it is
our duty to do that so that resonated
with me now this is seven eight years
ago uh even 10 years ago when five kids
first started out we'd have all these
comments on stuff like that and then the
pandemic hits
the the pandemic hit and the leader of
the Rat Pack leaves Joe Rogan leaves and
the comic store shuts down comedy La
shuts down then comes the girl leaves
and then Joey Diaz leaves then Tim
Dillon leaves the deal Von leaves and
then uh Brian goes through some [__]
me too movement and he has to leave and
kristalia goes some through some
[__] me too moving Chrisley has to
leave and I'm on this island by myself
I'm like whoa where's everybody I
thought let's all right the troops
although we're not in La we got a rally
let's rally around each other and it
broke my heart man it broke my that no
those days are over Dude you gotta
figure it out on your own those days are
over the days of you know being in the
in in the hallways at the Conway store
in The Improv and the ice house and
Laugh Factory where you know hey podcast
tomorrow yeah podcast one those days are
gone everyone's they've made it
everyone's in their game you gotta
figure it out on your own now it's weird
because
you know I was like Comedy Store last
night
and I always have this uh it takes me a
while I sit in the parking lot for a
while because it just kind of reminds me
when I pull up now that I used to pull
up and Rogue and pull up in this Porsche
and park next to each other and talk
shop about the cars and what's next and
then Santino would pull up and we talked
to him and Chris D'Elia and then Brian
would pull up and Bobby Lee and Theo and
we'd be in there and they're going to
college it was the best it was it was
the absolute best and I wish five six
seven years ago somebody would have
tapped us on the show like hey fellas in
two years this is all God
you I didn't realize at the moment that
that was the Golden Age and what we were
doing was so special we took it for
granted and I I didn't realize at the
time how special it was in in my in my
theater where my fish tank are and like
my man cave I have four pictures from
those days but I just put them up right
you know when they were done five six
seven years ago I didn't realize that in
that picture in that Frozen moment that
was the best time ever for for me as far
as uh just being in that symbiotic like
team it was such a team man yeah there's
a special moment you know now we're all
everyone's doing well we still talk we
have our group chats but as far as like
you know seeing each other all the time
like those days are over man and it's
heartbreaking yeah it's it's important
to have one of those like uh Pay It
Forward cultures because it's like that
I think silica Valley has that too which
which is there's not really that much
gatekeeping you can go to the most
successful richest guy in Silicon Valley
he'll give give you time it doesn't
matter who you are and if you need a
favor they'll give you a favor with
they'll give you either advice or money
or an intro and there's no like pay it
back it's all paid for because they got
helped by the person before them and
correctly that stayed together now like
you said with the pandemic a bunch of
people moved out of Silicon Valley so
who knows what will happen now it takes
a little longer in our world to to sort
of see those effects but I remember when
I was in San Francisco living in San
Francisco kind of on the come up me and
Sam met doing one of these like founder
masterminds where we would get dinner
for hours and talk like okay what are
you doing how's that going what am I
doing how's that going how can we help
each other out and it felt like um you
know in Toy Story when when they go to
that arcade and those little minions are
are in the machine and it's like the
claw and the cloth selects one and takes
it away and that's like you you know
they made it they they got the fame the
fortune they got picked but the other
minions weren't pulling them down they
were like pushing them up like his Grand
brother go for it you know like you know
you you made it out and because it's
like that in Silicon Valley you'll know
somebody and they're broke for the four
years you know them and then they're
worth 150 million dollars overnight and
then you're like yo the claw picked you
and you won yeah yeah the claw which is
Mark Zuckerberg buying your company
happened uh and like it's same thing in
entertainment someone hits a breakout
point and now they're famous they're you
know they made it and there's a question
of like does it do you just get left in
the dust do you resent people when
they're happening or do you you realize
that the rising tide lifts all boats and
you really want to be in that Rising
tide type of yeah in in just a side note
in San Francisco now pay it forward yeah
great you gotta worry about getting
stabbed out there forget starting
tonight will your friend watch it back
watch your back literally like you got
you gotta actually watch each other's
back physically just survive the day you
know Reina Ford is carrying a gun so
your buddy even gets stabbed in the net
yeah it's insane you uh I was gonna ask
a slightly different question but you I
saw a few interviews that were cool one
it was uh Donald cowboy Cerrone and then
Chael Sonnen and I think actually
Michael Bisping said the same thing
where they were talking about like in
the locker room before they fight and
they're like I think it was chill he's
like people think that like we're tough
guys and like maybe we we kind of are
but like every single time before a
fight I think
my last one should have been my last one
what am I doing I hate this and then
like Michael bisbing who's like a cocky
dude and like is very confident he was
like this is the worst thing ever and
then I think cowboy Cerrone was like I
throw up before every fight I'm so
afraid and then you had a really cool
thing where you're like I just beat up
uh Crow cop so if you don't listen if
you don't know anything about UFC Crow
cop is like one of the the goats of MMA
and he's scary as [__] like he's like
this Croatian dude but like you think
he's like a scary Russian RoboCop type
of guy and you knocked him out and I
remember like you said you're like I
knocked him out and backstage I went and
said like thank you or something or like
you know like a good fight and he like
had ice on his head and you're like what
the [__] am I doing I don't want to like
do this for my life I don't want to be
40 or 38 or however old he was when you
when you beat him up but uh what's that
like backstage the 15 30 minutes before
you're about to go fight to the death in
your underwear in front of a million
people yeah I think I don't I don't know
if I was the I might have been the one
the first fighters ever say that you
know but a lot of guys they want to give
off the Persona that oh were these
Warriors It's Like Gladiator we can't
wait to get out there but
I'm telling you so and I won't mention
names I've seen dudes cry backstage they
don't want to go out there I've seen
their coaches slap them like dude you
have to go out there it's just
I I just don't think it's natural you
know I think it's a level of
intelligence of your body and your mind
going hey you're about to get hurt do
not go out there so the anxiety is
through the roof and every fight I was
like what am I doing man I was like so
disappointing myself and then once I hit
the cage for most of my career I was
okay I knew it was time to get out when
I hit the cage and my dude don't get
hurt get out of here you got so much
more to do in this life you cannot you
know suffer a concussion we have got to
figure this out so you know I think
there's truth and honesty for most
Fighters where it's like it's terrifying
it's to me it was the worst gig in the
world there's some the highs are the
highest in the world the Peaks are the
best the valleys are the lowest there
can be in professional sports or maybe
in life it's a tough gig man you know so
I think the more Fighters talk about
like Hey we're human man and and it is
scary going out there and I think the
more Fighters talk about the more people
can relate to it because most people
have you ever man if if tonight you're
today after this the podcast you go to
the coffee shop and you're getting your
coffee and some guy goes you have some
altercation the guy goes hey man
tomorrow at 1pm you and I are fighting
you're like I guess we gotta fight
imagine the anxiety you can have that
night that morning walk in that coffee
shop and that's fighting Billy you know
from in San Francisco who's gonna you
know and fight you over coffee and he
probably don't have skills now height
net times a thousand not only do you
know exactly when you're getting a
fisticuff if the guy happens to be I
don't know top 10 the world at beating
people up in your underwear and
everybody's gonna see it you know what
I'm saying it's human nature to be like
this is not healthy dude we've been we
this dude this podcast and just our
friends it's been cool to like see some
of our friends become worth hundreds of
millions or even billion dollars and
it's cool because we'll talk to them
like just hanging out and they'll be
like I have to fire this person and I'm
so afraid to do it like I that I haven't
done it in like eight months like I'm
afraid of the confrontation and what
that does is it like normalizes fear and
you're like oh therefore I can do it and
I remember like thinking about like
Habib and like dude this guy is like
Terminator like he doesn't show that
much fear and then I saw some of these
other tough guys like say like oh no
like it's it's miserable I've always
wanted like a Conor or a Habib like some
of the the the most outspoken confident
guys I like I want to hear them say like
I'm about to piss my pants because
whenever I hear that I'm like that's
[__] cold I could do anything if this
guy's afraid if this guy's afraid which
I know they are even if they don't say
it I know they are I think there are
levels to like it does seem like there
are some guys like a Habib or something
like that where they're like they're
more stoic than others but there is like
there's always self-doubt and I think
it's really cool when I see some of
these killers like actually say that it
gives me like it oddly gives me hope
yeah I think it makes them human I you
know I think it would do athletes just
so much more in the public eye if you
know before the Super Bowl or even after
super autonomy like I'm scared shitless
man that defense was good you know I'm
terrified to get hit and throw
interceptions and fail I just think more
people would relate to it because
whatever were there ever any athletes
that you know of or hung out with MMA
guys or boxers where they were built
different where they're like this
person's looking forward to a fight or
do you think unilaterally it was no
there's there's people where you know
ignorance is bliss right you know it's
like there there's guys I trained with
and I I'd be two weeks out from the
fight you know in the camps tailoring
down I'm like oh man the fight's in two
weeks man Saturdays but you guys are
good no exciting right I'm like no do
this is terrible but dates just there's
certain guys where they live for you
know those guys like the the Diaz
brothers even though they said that they
hate fighting I think there's some guy
like a Kane Velasquez there's certain
guys that just thrive in that just
engage you who they just they just love
the violence they just there's nothing
they were just born Warriors you know
they're not thinking about businesses or
you know uh 10 years down the road or 15
years down the road it's just they were
meant to do this and God bless them you
need people like that God bless them
even if you're not in the UFC if you're
listening to this go and look up Justin
Gacy post fight Michael Chandler on
YouTube he said this amazing thing he
goes I was born in the wrong era I
should have been a gladiator so I could
kill this person in front of all of you
because that's what I'm built to do and
that's what I love I'm here to fight to
the death and I heard that and I'm like
there's there's two different types of
humans I'm one and he's the other
yeah this is crazy true and I think you
know I I think for me it came to
realization because I've known Justin
gaichi since she was in college I used
to go up to University of Northern
Colorado and wrestle to get ready for my
USC fight so I saw just at a young age
he's always been like that and again
when I'd be in the locker rooms or we'd
be in the training camps and those guys
would talk like that
you know don't get me wrong I'm built
like a warrior like uh you'd look at me
I think that's one of the reasons I get
paid from these guys I think it's okay
to treat me the way that I that they do
because you know I look like a gladiator
I'm this big dude with tattoos and
cauliflower ears but really push come to
shove I'm the guy behind going
to feel like I don't want to be in the
front [__] lines man that's not what
I want to do you know so
so I get the treatment of these Warriors
but really I'm the guy in the back
playing the trombone holding the flag
you know making sure I look good one of
our Sean and I talked about this after a
rose named Eunice this uh uh UFC fighter
she uh like before the fight you see her
saying I'm the best I'm the best I'm the
best and it doesn't matter if you like
UFC or not it makes you cry because
you're just like there's so much like
you have to talk yourself up to this and
it's just so like motivational inspiring
cute I don't know what you want to call
it but it's awesome it's like one of my
favorite moments of seeing her say that
and then afterwards Joe goes I saw you
saying you're the best what's up with
that and she goes because I am the best
and you like you're convincing herself
yeah that she's the best so much
self-doubt and he's just like no you're
the best and because and I'm assuming
she worked with a mental coach which I
did too when I was fighting you work
with these high-level Mentor coaches
they tell you that you fight the
negative thought in your head with a
positive you say it out loud so that's
just for freaking trying to keep the the
demons at the door good I'm the best I'm
the best you know what I love about this
podcast is usually when people bring up
fighting and for me it's a nightmare
it's that nightmare like especially if I
if I'm doing a a show outside like
whether it's a comedy central if it's a
TV show they talk fighting usually they
have no clue about UFC like even you
brought up Rose you brought up Justin
gaichi and the Michael Chandler stuff
like thank God you guys have an insight
into the UFC like current UFC World I'll
give you some shows and be like so
what's your take on chuckled down for
and Tank Abbott I think that's still
gonna happen dude they have Alzheimer's
man they're not having it anymore how is
Conrad McGregor doing
no man we're super fans that's why uh
that's why it's cool to hang out with
you we've had we've talked I've talked
to Michael Bisping been asking we've had
Ariel helwani on your voice I know you
guys had uh you guys had a spat uh we've
had uh who else uh a bunch of people in
that world it's always fun to talk to
you guys because like even though like
the intensity level that you're doing
it's like literally life and death
starting a business is like a percentage
of that but it's like I can't do this
I'm freaking out I don't know how to do
this like you constantly feel like
inferior oh there's similarities with
all of it with all of it whether you're
a UFC fighter your entrepreneur there's
similarities where you bake on yourself
it's on you and the peaks of valleys are
insane either way so there's takeaways
from both sides you know there's they
definitely overlap you know you
mentioned Arrow Hawaii right and I
there's that and I think it's a fan
thing you know I've had spats with over
the years it's gonna happen I don't
really entertain it but I have no
animosity towards Ariel you know I'll do
interviews whether whatever it is going
to go so you and Dana don't like each
other no I have no animal I I don't
dislike anybody you know I think that
might be one of the reasons too why the
haters they can't stand it because
they they want that they want that drama
they want something to feed off of they
call it feeding the trolls I just don't
entertain that I think that is you know
upsets them it's just not what I do so
when Aaron and I were having our thing
man I made a mistake I was on the fight
campaign I said some things I shouldn't
have said he was rightfully slowly get
upset and did his thing all good man
that's how it goes you know I take your
accountability there that's on me but
here is the best journalist we have I
listen to a show you know I have no
issues with Ariel with Dana man if
anything I probably should be giving
data 10 because when he made that deal
with Reebok it you know
at the time I was a young man at the
time I took it personal I thought it was
a hit of against me and it put a chip on
my when I say chip out of entire
Pringles
and what you're talking about is uh
before you could put any logo you want
then you made a deal with Reebok and
it's just they are the guys yeah I lost
you know probably a hundred thousand
dollars a fight and you know and I took
it personal but being a business owner
now Dana was at mate when the Reebok
deal came man how's this going to affect
Brendan Shaw no dude I'm one of the you
know I'm one of the elephants in the
circus you gotta do what's great for all
the elephants not just me so I was you
know a bystander and the casualty of
that deal just didn't work out in my
favor but that pushed me faster into
what I was supposed to be doing so Damon
actually helped me out I have zero issue
with Dana huge fan huge fan but I think
fans some people for whatever reason
they can't get over that it's like well
no he screwed you over and look and you
have to retire and he did this I'm like
no he did me a favor guys that was 12
years ago it's all good he's doing great
he's worth more money than God I'm doing
pretty good at zero if he called me
today I was like hey man we need you to
do this no doubt I'll help you out no
problem
well dude you're the man you um I said
earlier that we had Rob on and he like I
knew Rob grown up as a skater and then
he came on and he like just surprised us
so much I think his his video has uh
hundreds of thousands of views that when
we did with him which is good for us and
uh you're kind of in that category where
you're where I'm like I had good
expectations uh because I listened to
you a lot but you're a lot more
insightful than I thought and I thought
you were pretty insightful and and
you're
you're just a good guess maybe next time
you'll have a better uh setup instead of
just being on your iPhone yeah yeah so
here here's the thing about that so I
don't own a computer my company like
thick Boy network has whatever 12 15
computers
um I'm like that anti
um I'm the anti kind of Technology guy I
don't like it seems that seems good for
a internet company owner I know right
Mark yeah can you tell I'm gonna fail by
next year so yeah we did the same with
uh there's a guy Mark Laurie who bought
the Timberwolves he he's a like famous
entrepreneur he's a billionaire he came
on he was doing the same thing he's like
is this good guys they put his iPhone on
a chair on top of his dining table and
he stood up and he talked and we were
like do you can you use your computer I
don't I don't own a computer and we were
like it hits different when a
billionaire says it it's like you know
if somebody else says it you're just
like man what a schmuck and then you
hear him say you're like this guy knows
this guy knows how to live okay
he's got a person you know he's got
people you know what I'm saying he's
like I don't have computers but I have
humans yeah no I I know you guys next
time we do this I'll do an athlete boy
Studios usually every Wednesday I'm in
studio but uh today because
um yesterday I did three podcasts in a
row that a two-hour meeting for this new
project I'm doing so I start at 7 30 a.m
and then by the time I got done with
that meeting I was I was home around
five went and bought my kids lizards put
fed them dinner went put them to bed
then rushed Over The Comedy Store and I
got home at 12 30 last night so today is
my first off day and I don't know how
long and then tomorrow I'm on tour in
Atlanta Thursday Friday Saturday I'm in
Atlanta doing shows so usually I'm
always in studio and I have the team set
up so it looks professional so I owe you
guys I owe you guys but I I hate
electric cars I think they're a disaster
I don't like electric cars I don't like
iPhones I'm about to switch to a flip
phone I just I don't I just don't
subscribe drive to it man I don't think
it's healthy let's add a couple zeros to
your net worth and then we'll call it
cool but until then look like a tool
right now you're a [__] caveman
you're a caveman but like maybe maybe
just I've done a few zeros and we'll
call you a genius but until then you're
you're Neanderthal yeah yeah until then
I'm just this broke guy doing a lot of
iPhone step well dude thank you for
doing this you're amazing and we and we
we appreciate it thanks for coming on
yeah besides my setup this got sad fast
at the end
um all right that's the episode
[Music]
foreign